y
[Música]
hola bienvenidos a kobe 19 la semana en
américa soy santiago lópez gonzález este
es el espacio de france 24 en el que
hacemos un resumen de las principales
noticias relacionadas con la pandemia
del cob y 19 en nuestro continente
américa a continuación les presento los
temas que hemos preparado para la
edición de hoy
vamos a hablar de la decisión de las
autoridades sanitarias de eeuu de
aprobar el uso del plasma como otro
mecanismo para luchar contra el
coronavirus conversaremos con un
especialista invitado a partir del
primero de septiembre de varios países
de las regiones de américa latina'
comenzarán también a levantar de manera
escalonada las restricciones impuestas
para combatir la pandemia esto incluye
la reactivación comercial y social pero
con algunas restricciones también la
reactivación de los vuelos comerciales
las clases presenciales entre otros
temas vamos a ver entonces cómo va
evolucionando dependiendo de los casos y
les contaremos la historia de titto una
llama peruana cuya sangre está siendo
estudiada para buscar otros medios
alternativos para desarrollar mecanismos
que permitan también combatir el
coronavirus 'tito' y su aporte a la
ciencia estará al cierre de este
programa vamos a comenzar entonces
ya lo decíamos la administración federal
de alimentos y fármacos de estados
unidos la fed autorizó el uso de plasma
convaleciente como una terapia para
tratar a los pacientes que tienen kobe
19 tras haber sido probado en unas
70.000 personas en eeuu en nuestra
región algunos países como por ejemplo
costa rica han avanzado ampliamente en
su estudio y también en su uso para
analizar este tema invitamos al señor o
al doctor mejor josé gonzález zamora de
las especialista en enfermedades
infecciosas de la universidad de miami
en el estado de florida y también es
investigador del plasma convaleciente
doctor gonzález gracias por estar con
nosotros en france 24 y comienzo por
preguntarle partiendo del punto inicial
que este uso del plasma no es una vacuna
que es este plasma convaleciente y para
qué sirve
bueno es el plasma del convalenciente se
tiene que entender como eso es una
medida terapéutica recientemente
aprobada por la fd a que nos va a
permitir un uso más amplio y
generalizado a nivel del país y
básicamente el plazo es un componente de
la sangre que va a tener muchos
elementos constituyentes pero uno de los
cuales es la dos los anticuerpos
neutralizantes que son aquellos que ha
formado una persona que se ha recuperado
de la enfermedad estos anticuerpos
neutralizantes tienen el objetivo o la
función de inhibir o bloquear la
replicación viral es así que este plazo
del convaleciente de esta persona
recuperada se va a transfundir a una
persona que está activamente enferma que
tiene el virus replicándose de manera
activa con el objetivo de inhibir esta
replicación viral de bloquear al virus y
de esta manera obtener una mejoría
clínica y posiblemente una reducción de
la mortalidad doctor gonzález la fedea
señaló que los ensayos clínicos
iniciales demuestran que la técnica es
completamente segura para los pacientes
pero varios científicos también han
argumentado que no ha sido
suficientemente probada para dar certeza
de eso que piensa usted al respecto
yo creo que es una apreciación correcta
sabemos al momento que el plasma del
compareciente es una medida que es
ciertamente segura ya que en este
estudio de la clínica mayo con 35 mil
pacientes
solamente menos del 1 por ciento tuvo
desarrollo que tuvo el desarrollo de
efectos adversos atribuidos al plasma
del convaleciente así que se
consideramos estos datos este plasma del
compareciente tiene un alto perfil de
seguridad pero con relación a los
beneficios clínicos nosotros tenemos
muchos pacientes que han recibido el
plasma de convalecientes y aparentemente
tenemos un resultado muy favorable ya
que estos pacientes mejoran clínicamente
me refiero disminución o mejoría de sus
síntomas y también posiblemente haya una
reducción de la mortalidad pero esto
último está por demostrarse todavía ya
que no contamos a la fecha con ensayos
clínicos fase 3 que demuestren una
eficacia real del plasma del
convaleciente pero estos ensayos
clínicos están llevándose a cabo al
momento y esperemos que al término de
ellos también podamos demostrar el un
beneficio absoluto de este plazo del
convaleciente doctor también está estos
estudios iniciales han demostrado que
las personas
son menores de 80 años que no estaban
conectadas a un respirador artificial y
que han recibido este plasma se han
beneficiado más con este tratamiento su
mejoría ha sido más rápida el proceso ha
sido benéfico para ellos tienen entonces
los pacientes que tener algún tipo de
características en el desarrollo del
virus en cada uno de los casos para para
poder determinar si lo va a beneficiar
más o menos o si en unos casos si se
debe aplicar y en otros no
al momento la indicación para la
aplicación del plasma de convalecencia
son aquellas personas que tienen
neumonía severa y que están
hospitalizadas y me refiero con esto a
personas que están utilizando oxígeno
suplementario y que tengan un compromiso
aproximadamente de 50 por ciento de los
campos pulmonares sabemos a la fecha que
el beneficio más grande del plasma del
convalenciente es en la etapa temprana
de la enfermedad me refiero que los tres
primeros días de hospitalización es
donde vemos un beneficio clínico mucho
más grande si lo comparamos con otras
personas que recibieron el plasma de
convalenciente en una etapa más tardía y
también se ha asociado la cantidad de
anticuerpos neutralizantes con el
beneficio clínico a más anticuerpos
neutralizantes más beneficio clínico
doctor una duda y está acá sí que es una
duda personal de este plasma como ya
usted lo explicó viene de la sangre de
pacientes que ya han padecido la
enfermedad pero que hay entonces de
estos casos de personas que han sido ya
registrados en hong kong en bélgica y en
los países bajos que están padeciendo
kobe 19 por una segunda vez que están
siendo re infectados otra vez
supuestamente ya no tenían algún nivel
de anticuerpos
en su organismo que les permita
defenderse como entender estos casos con
respecto a este uso del plasma
bueno hay que comprender que los
anticuerpos neutralizantes que se
desarrollan a partir de una infección
posiblemente no sean tan duraderos hay
estudios que nos dicen que estos
anticuerpos neutralizantes pueden durar
de dos a tres meses y estos estudios
provienen del reino unido- y del
continente asiático así que hay unos
indicios al momento de que estos
anticuerpos no nos vayan a proteger por
un tiempo muy prolongado y posiblemente
esto lo que ha sucedido porque para
nuestros pacientes provenientes de hong
kong y también dos casos reportados en
europa al momento si analizamos el caso
de hong kong específicamente en el
segundo episodio episodio de infección
este paciente no desarrolló ningún
síntoma de la enfermedad simplemente ese
respecto es así que creemos que tal vez
la inmunidad no nos proteja contra la
reinfección pero sí nos proteja contra
el desarrollo de síntomas producidos por
él con una virus claramente no tener
síntomas de tener síntomas y haber
estado hospitalizado a no presentar
ningún tipo de síntomas en el caso de
este paciente de hong kong pues es un
gran alivio en este caso para la persona
no tiene que estar otra vez
hospitalizada y sometida a terapias como
los respiradores artificiales quiero
preguntarle por la región de américa
como estamos nosotros en los estudios
sobre el uso del plasma en los países
que lo están usando puede ser una
oportunidad para nuestra región que ha
tenido tantos problemas para hacer
frente a esta pandemia
sí yo creo que es una muy grande una
oportunidad muy grande para américa
latina para usar este plazo de
convaleciente ya sea en el contexto de
ensayo clínico o en el contexto de
acceso expandido o el uso compasivo yo
creo que ante la carencia de medidas o
de antivirales a nivel de américa latina
pero que el plasma de convalecientes es
una opción terapéutica muy válida y que
podría aplicarse de una manera más
amplia dado el contexto en que vivimos
doctor rápidamente jonathan rainer que
es un profesor de medicina de la
universidad george washington en eeuu
consideró que este anuncio hecho por la
feria el lunes en eeuu tiene unos tintes
políticos debido al inicio de la campaña
del presidente de trump que pienso hasta
el respecto
yo creo que pueden haber muchas
interpretaciones pero lo que sí
podríamos decir desde el punto de vista
científico es que existen algunos
indicios de que hay un beneficio clínico
del plazo del convaleciente y que esos
indicios fueron suficientemente grandes
para hacer para convencer a la fed de
hacer un uso o la autorización o hacer
la autorización de este uso del plazo de
convaleciente claro que claro está que
necesitamos más estudios y esperemos que
los estudios de eficacia finales nos
demuestren también este plasma del
convaleciente es una medida realmente
útil doctor gonzález muy clara su
explicación muchas gracias por haber
estado con nosotros en france 24 y
habernos aclarado las dudas en torno a
este tema del uso del plasma
convaleciente muchas gracias
vamos a avanzar con otros temas colombia
es uno de los países de la región que
como decíamos va a poner fin a la
cuarentena a partir del primero de
septiembre 'ecuador permitirá a partir
de esa fecha también la apertura de las
playas aunque mantiene el toque de queda
en algunas de las ciudades con la
mayoría de las ciudades mientras tanto
perú amplió el estado de emergencia
hasta el 30 de septiembre y argentina
anunció que mantendrá el confinamiento
selectivo hasta el 20 de septiembre
veamos en detalle cómo colombia se está
preparando para esta reapertura
económica comercial y social con
restricciones
colombia entrará en una nueva fase sin
cuarentenas a partir del primero de
septiembre la medida pondrá fin a uno de
los confinamientos más extensos del
mundo ya que de forma parcial o total se
han restringido los movimientos de los
ciudadanos desde el 25 de marzo en el
primero de septiembre empieza una nueva
fase donde cambiamos el concepto de
aislamiento preventivo obligatorio con
un número importante de excepciones a
que tengamos un concepto de aislamiento
selectivo de distanciamiento y
responsabilidad individual el encierro
prolongado ha causado que el pib
colombiano cayese un 74 por ciento en el
primer semestre del año algo que han
sentido especialmente los comerciantes
que horas antes del anuncio salieron en
bogotá a protestar por su situación la
falta de ayudas durante estos meses ha
causado que en numerosos
establecimientos se hayan visto
obligados a cerrar cinco meses golpeados
económicamente por parte de la
administración distrital aquí están
hablando de ayudas a los comerciantes
para qué
empleado le lleguen subsidios eso no es
cierto no ha llegado pero el virus está
lejos de ser controlado en colombia el
país registra cifras de contagio
superiores a los 10 mil casos diarios y
los decesos oscilan entre los 250 y los
400 diarios en las últimas semanas
pues ya lo veíamos en colombia pese a
las dramáticas cifras de contagio las
cifras de fallecidos y recuperados han
comenzado a mejorar y eso es lo que ha
permitido a las autoridades levantar
parcialmente la cuarentena vamos a
conocer también cómo están la situación
en bolivia vamos a comenzar hablando con
nuestros corresponsales destacados en
estas dos ciudades en bogotá y en la paz
para analizar la situación comenzó
entonces con luís muñoz en la capital
colombiana
lluís y cómo será entonces el desmonte
de esta cuarentena y el inicio de la
reactivación de la vida económica de la
vida comercial y de la vida social pero
con algunas restricciones que ha
anunciado el gobierno
así es santiago como escuchábamos al
presidente iván duque desde el 1 de
septiembre después de cinco meses de
cuarentena pasaremos de un aislamiento
obligatorio a un aislamiento selectivo
qué significa esto pues que
prácticamente todas las actividades se
podrán desarrollar excepto aquellas que
tengan pues aglomeraciones que supongan
aglomeraciones como los eventos
deportivos masivos o eventos también
musicales como conciertos también
volverán los viajes que es un tema que
se ha debatido
tanto por carretera como también por
aire de momento sólo se conocen rutas
por aire nacionales pero también se
esperan que las internacionales vuelvan
pronto a destacar como dices que por
ejemplo en el caso de bogotá había una
cuarentena restrictiva hasta el
miércoles y desde el jueves hemos podido
ver en las calles que ha vuelto el
tranco en el clásico tráfico colombiano
también se ve en una actividad de los
restaurantes e incluso la informalidad
ya ocupa las calles si se ha compensado
haber mucha más actividad en las calles
colombianas lluís hablemos del sistema
hospitalario porque las cifras en
colombia siguen siendo muy altas en
torno a los contagios y a las personas
que están siendo atendidas pese a esto
el país no ha colapsado en su sistema
sanitario pero entonces cómo está la
situación porque si ordenan una apertura
es porque los hospitales deben de estar
bien preparados creo que es importante
fijarnos en el caso de bogotá no
actualmente a día de hoy las unidades de
cuidados intensivos están a un 76 por
ciento pero a finales de julio llegaron
a estar a un 93 por ciento
por una parte sí que ha ido remitiendo
el virus pero también podemos decir que
el aumento la multiplicación de camas de
unidades de cuidados intensivos que a
día de hoy en bogotá por ejemplo se
sitúan en más de 1300 han ayudado que no
colapse el sistema hospitalario también
es indicador corferias la feria de
bogotá se convirtió en un hospital y
nunca llegó tampoco a llenarse de hecho
sólo se usó el 10 por ciento del
presupuesto algo que la alcaldesa
claudia lópez ha dicho que el dinero
restante se va a utilizar pues en
inversiones para luchar contra el cob y
19 como rastreadores de hecho después de
estas de la apertura no se sabe muy bien
qué va a pasar no pero sí que uno de
nuestros médicos carlos pérez ayer en
twitter hacía referencia a que la masiva
presencia de personas en las calles
convertían a bogotá en una especie de
kobe land no de la cantidad de personas
que había que podían estar transmitiendo
el virus sin embargo las autoridades
confían en que está remisión del virus
vaya a continuar y también pues que la
responsabilidad ciudadana ayude a que no
se disparen los contagios nuevamente
el doctor pérez que es uno de nuestros
asesores médicos y científicos de france
24 finalmente para terminar guys quiero
hablar del escenario económico colombia
ha tenido serios problemas para hacer
este balance entre la seguridad
sanitaria de los habitantes y mantener
la economía a flote una economía que
está muy focalizada en
en ser informal y eso ha dificultado que
las personas hayan tenido que permanecer
en sus casas y aguardar allí teniendo la
necesidad de salir a trabajar para
simplemente poder comer en el día a día
sí creo que también eso ha influido en
el cambio de las cuarentenas no claudia
lópez la alcaldesa de bogotá se adelantó
en sus planes y de hecho había
localidades que el miércoles estaban en
una cuarentena estricta y el jueves ya
estaban totalmente abiertas este
adelanto de planes tiene que ver se dice
que es por las presiones sociales que
están habiendo y por el temor a que haya
un estallido social después de que en
las últimas semanas se estén también
repitiendo manifestaciones de distintos
sectores económicos que se han visto muy
perjudicados por la cuarentena de hecho
la economía cadena colombiana en el
segundo trimestre cayó un 15 por ciento
mientras que el desempleo aumentó en un
25% ante esta situación el gobierno hoy
precisamente ha anunciado una ayuda de
protección social que significará para
las personas que no lleguen al salario
mínimo una ayuda para completar y que
puedan también continuar su vida de la
mejor forma en un salario mínimo
colombia es de 200 dólares lluís pues a
partir del primero de septiembre todas
estas medidas entrarán en vigor y más
adelante pues estaremos analizando con
el paso de los días cómo va surtiendo
efecto estas medidas del gobierno
colombiano muchas gracias el gobierno de
bolivia también anunció que va a
flexibilizar allí en este país las
medidas de cuarentena después de cinco
meses de confinamiento como dijo la
presidenta interina para evitar el
korona hambre que es la situación más
complicada que están haciendo ahorita
frente a los bolivianos vamos a saludar
entonces a meriva casi en la ciudad de
la paz mery como será entonces el
escenario del post confinamiento como lo
han denominado allí en bolivia porque el
virus como vemos persiste sigue y la
emergencia continúa
hola qué tal santiago tengo que decirte
que es una medida bastante polémica la
que ha tomado la presidenta jeanine áñez
porque de inmediato han salido los
médicos e incluso asesores del
ministerio de salud para decir que esto
no era lo que se esperaba que no se
debería terminar con la cuarentena y
pasar a esta nueva etapa de post
confinamiento pues consideran que puede
existir un nuevo colapso de hospital es
un brote del virus más aún tomando en
cuenta que hubo muchas protestas
sociales marchas masivas asambleas en
las diferentes ciudades del país en todo
caso debo comentarles que según los
datos de la universidad johns hopkins la
curva en bolivia empieza a descender sin
embargo sin embargo todavía está en un
nivel muy alto de la fecha sé que
existen más de 113 mil infectados en el
país y se aproxima el país a tener 5 mil
muertos por kobe 19 sin embargo como
decíamos la presidenta ha justificado
esta decisión indicando que de otra
así es que no se producía la apertura
económica iba a llegar el corona hambre
en alusión a los bolivianos que
necesitan salir a trabajar y que no han
podido hacerlo en todo caso a partir de
ahora lo que se puede es hacer de todo
hasta las 8 de la noche y a partir de
esa hora
otra vez existen las restricciones hasta
las 5 de la mañana del día siguiente los
vuelos están permitidos tanto nacionales
como internacionales las fronteras
terrestres van a permanecer cerradas y
también están prohibidas las actividades
masivas es decir se ha abierto la
economía de lunes a domingo de lunes a
viernes hasta las 8 de la noche y los
fines de semana hasta las 4 de la tarde
media al igual que colombia la situación
económica de bolivia no es fácil como es
el panorama en este país suramericano
pues bolivia está teniendo unos
registros históricos respecto a la
contracción económica el banco central
de bolivia ha previsto una contracción
de menos 6.2 para este año pero acaba de
salir el informe del instituto nacional
de estadística sobre el índice global de
actividad económica que dice que la
caída es de 7.9 por ciento y eso ha
tenido su correlato directo en el
desempleo que normalmente en bolivia
estaba por encima del 3% pero que ahora
se sitúa en más del 11% y la mayor parte
de esta gente ha quedado sin empleo a
causa de la cuarentena todo esto ha
configurado un escenario de crisis
económica en el país con cierre de
empresas despidos y gente que no está
pudiendo pagar sus créditos
mary no puedo dejar de preguntarle por
esa nueva controversia que hay en
bolivia en torno a unos respiradores
chinos también hace unas semanas atrás
veíamos otra controversia por unos
respiradores españoles que es lo que
está pasando ahora con los que han
llegado desde el país asiático
pues santiago pareciera que en bolivia a
comprar respiradores es un dolor de
cabeza como tú decías la compra de los
respiradores españoles ocurrida en mayo
ha quedado prácticamente en nada es
decir el estado ha perdido una
millonaria cifra y esos respiradores
están tomando polvo en algunos almacenes
del país porque no tienen ninguna
utilidad y ahora sucede que bolivia ha
comprado 324 respiradores chinos y
también han llegado al país en medio de
una fuerte polémica porque hay denuncias
de sobreprecio según el gobierno se ha
pagado más de 35 mil dólares por cada
uno de esos respiradores pero también ha
reconocido el propio ejecutivo que son
respiradores tenían un costo no mayor a
18 mil 500 dólares en todo caso la
justificación del pago adicional es que
se ha tenido que cubrir costos de
pasajes impuestos y además de
instalación la polémica está servida
porque además los médicos que están
usando estos respiradores han señalado
desde diferentes partes del país que
muchos de ellos presentan fallas y que
no están sirviendo para tratar a los
enfermos de kobe 19 en ese marco se han
presentado ya dos demandas penales otra
vez en contra del gobierno por haber
comprado estos respiradores con supuesto
sobreprecio pero pues seguiremos también
atentos al desarrollo de esta polémica
muchas gracias por este reporte desde la
ciudad de la paz
y esta semana unos 24 millones de
estudiantes mexicanos retomaron clases
virtuales después del receso de verano
el gobierno federal ha dudado en
considerar el escenario nacional como
seguro para poder decretar la apertura
de las escuelas y las clases
presenciales por este motivo apostó por
un ambicioso programa educativo que es
transmitido por radio y por televisión
un reto muy grande para esta nación con
60 millones de personas que están bajo
el umbral de la pobreza y que no tienen
acceso a tecnología y mucho menos a
conexión de internet
esta semana millones de hogares
mexicanos encendieron temprano su
televisor pero no para ver noticias el
aparato que el 93 por ciento de los
mexicanos tiene en casa estaba el
proyecto algo que nunca antes había
transmitido clases para cerca de 30
millones de estudiantes de escuelas
públicas que permanecerán cerradas al
menos hasta fin de año debido a la
pandemia pero esta primera semana ha
sido un caos para maestros estudiantes y
profesores en la televisión pues no
contamos con el sistema por ejemplo en
canales que se está dando cursos estos
no contamos con nuestros canales
el gobierno mexicano apostó por un
ambicioso plan educativo en línea en el
que se planteó grabar un programa
completo para todos los grados escolares
ya que según el instituto nacional de
estadística y geografía de méxico sólo
el 56 por ciento de los hogares tiene
acceso a internet pero aunque el
gobierno dijo haber capacitado a más de
un millón de profesores para esta
operación la falta de recursos de
algunos maestros y estudiantes y las
fallas en infraestructura y señal en
algunos de los territorios más alejados
despertaron las dudas sobre si el
programa funcionará en un país con cerca
de la mitad
habitantes en situación de pobreza y
ahora sí en casa puedo hacer peor las
cosas pero
a ver que aprendiendo pero si como que
si da tristeza que pobres niños no
puedan ir a la escuela algunos expertos
señalan que estos obstáculos podrían
disparar la tasa de deserción escolar
una preocupación que parece estar
respaldada por la onu que advirtió que
méxico podría retroceder a un promedio
de 13 años de escolaridad por persona
debido a la pandemia y méxico también
hace frente a la crisis económica debido
a la pandemia del cob y 19 y esto ha
llevado a que muchos padres mexicanos
hayan tenido que retirar a sus hijos de
las escuelas privadas y trasladarlos al
sistema público de educación provocando
también un reto para las autoridades
educativas mexicanas está la situación
desde hace 21 años erekat eran té en el
jardín de niños y estancia infantil un
mundo del nuevo milenio y en los últimos
seis meses lo que ha construido está a
punto de venirse abajo pues los papás de
80% de los niños no pueden pagar ya las
cuotas y se han ido con lo que pasó de
la pandemia
estella me es muy difícil atraer a a mi
hija por falta de recursos y el panorama
para erika es incierto esta situación de
la pandemia vino a afectarnos se podría
decir a un 100 por ciento estamos
tomando la decisión de probablemente
cerrar para el próximo mes por la falta
de niños en méxico hay 40.000 escuelas
privadas de todos los niveles y cerca de
15.000 de ellas especialmente de
primaria y secundaria enfrentan
dificultades y cuando pase el periodo de
inscripciones se verá cuántas habrán
tenido que cerrar los estudiantes que se
están saliendo en términos generales va
a ser alrededor de más de millón y medio
de estudiantes que han estado
descartando de las escuelas particulares
se están yendo a las escuelas oficiales
las autoridades aseguran que tienen
capacidad
para enfrentar esta realidad esa
migración que se debe de escuelas
privadas de forma natural por la
condición económica en méxico tenemos
200 mil escuelas en básica en el país y
un millón doscientos mil maestros de
manera que están preparados para recibir
esta migración el sub-secretario es
optimista no así las madres que no
tendrán quienes cuidan sus hijos si
cierran las estancias privadas por la
crisis
mi hija come desayuna aquí todos los
días de lunes a viernes
y el que lo cierre me afecta demasiado
porque yo trabajo trabajo y yo no tengo
el tiempo para poder estar con ella en
las tardes además de dueños de escuelas
padres y alumnos otros afectados son los
maestros pues según la asociación de
escuelas particulares unos 200.000
trabajadores del sector educativo
podrían quedarse sin trabajo la isla de
cuba preparo ambiciosamente el regreso a
las clases en todos los niveles
educativos a partir del primero de
septiembre aunque con algunas
excepciones en las provincias de
artemisa y mayabeque asimismo el
gobierno cubano instauró el toque de
queda en la capital la ciudad de la
habana debido al rebrote de el
coronavirus llama la atención que
incluso en los momentos más complicados
de la pandemia a lo largo de estos cinco
meses en esta isla no fue impuesta a una
medida tan rigurosa como la que acaban
de imponer en la capital
jose goitía nos daba más detalles desde
la ciudad de la habana
con las sanciones de un donald trump en
plena campaña electoral y el pasó esta
semana de la tormenta tropical aura la
isla enfrenta una situación extrema pero
no puede pretender fallar en los dos
temas que siempre han sido los favoritos
es un sistema socialista salud y
educación
también se prevé sistematizar las
pesquisas en los centros educacionales
este sábado la ministra de educación
dará los últimos detalles y precisará el
plan para la capital y las provincias
confinadas donde se transmitirán clases
por televisión hasta la vuelta a la
normalidad
dejamos cubanos vamos hasta el sur del
continente en chile avanza el plan de
apertura llamado paso a paso esto ha
permitido que varios restaurantes abran
nuevamente algunos de ellos han puesto
en marcha sus cocinas para preparar
menús especialmente diseñados para las
familias más humildes de este país
suramericano una iniciativa que ha sido
muy bien recibida por la sociedad
chilena así están las cosas
si le creía erradicado el hambre pero
los meses de pandemia la trajeron de
regreso a los barrios populares de
santiago
la chef carolina bazán decidió entonces
dejar atrás las preparaciones elaboradas
que acostumbraban hacer en su
restaurante para concentrarse en comida
más sencilla ella fue escogida el año
pasado como la mejor chef en el concurso
50 mejores restaurantes de américa
latina'
todas las ganas de que quede lo mejor
posible de llegar a todas las casas de
la mejor manera posible del lado de las
gradas es arroz con pollo a la mostaza
en este barrio de clase obrera nueve
mujeres se unieron para entregar 165
almuerzos cada día a vecinos que
perdieron su trabajo y que aún no han
recibido ayudas estatales no es eso lo
que nos motiva a nosotros a nosotros no
solamente a mí a nosotros de estar acá
todos los días
de darle comida una comida de una trata
más de lo mejor comida que tú coma no
pura agua no sé si mañana podemos darla
entonces si lo podemos dar a horas de mi
comida digna
si bien no tenían mayor experiencia en
la cocina recurrieron a lo vivido en
este mismo lugar en los años 80 cuando
la crisis económica llevó a multiplicar
las ollas comunes en chile y hace cinco
meses que no han dado nada y por lo que
me dan ello no nada porque ellos me
traen la comida diaria y el pan todo lo
que varias fundaciones han cifrado en al
menos 400 los comedores populares
surgidos en todo santiago durante la
pandemia en muchos casos sirven la única
comida diaria para las familias
en nuestra sección en redes veamos otras
noticias destacadas de la semana aquí en
kobe 19 la semana en américa la cámara
de diputados y el senado de la república
dominicana dieron el visto bueno para
prorrogar por 45 días más el estado de
emergencia en ese país decretado por el
rápido aumento de los contagios de
coronavirus la medida le permitirá al
gobierno nacional mantener el toque de
queda en santo domingo en la capital la
medida es aún más restrictiva por ser la
zona de mayor incidencia de este virus
y las autoridades de bahamas jamaica
trinidad y tobago las islas cayman entre
otros territorios insulares en el caribe
así como surinam en suramérica han
mostrado su preocupación ante el fuerte
aumento de los casos de kobe 19 en los
últimos días en bahamas
los contagios superan ya los 1800 mil de
ellos solamente en la zona capital
en surinam hay 20 personas en cuidado
intensivo en un país que solamente tiene
capacidad para atender a 166 pacientes
en cuidado intensivo todos están
concentrados en paramaribo la capital
el sistema de surinam registra 3600
casos que se pueden complicar en los
próximos días y entrar a las salas de
cuidado intensivo intensivo su sistema o
pital hospitalario está presentando ya
saturación
y el congreso de guatemala aprobó la
sexta prórroga del estado de calamidad
en ese país centroamericano durante la
plenaria llovieron críticas al gobierno
del presidente ya alejandro giammatei
por el manejo de la pandemia que deja
más de 70 mil casos confirmados
guatemala fue uno de los primeros países
de américa central en permitir una
apertura de la vida económica y social
en esa nación
la llama es un animal fuertemente ligado
a la cultura inca en perú y podría
volver a tener un rol protagónico esta
vez en el desarrollo de un mecanismo que
sirva para combatir el kobe 19 a partir
de la sangre de este animal les
presentamos la historia de titto una
llama que está sirviendo para este
proceso científico que de funcionar
podría salvar miles de vidas en ese país
a sus casi seis años tito se ha
convertido en la esperanza de
científicos peruanos quienes estudian un
posible tratamiento contra el coi 19
empleando una microscópica fracción de
sus defensas que se encuentran en los
linfocitos de su sangre lo que buscamos
en el proyecto es precisamente producir
un anticuerpo específico para esta
proteína el virus para que bloquee la
unión del virus a la célula y evite la
infección evita que el virus ingrese a
la célula y causa la enfermedad los
investigadores introdujeron el
coronavirus a 'tito' para que genere una
respuesta inmune y le permita
desarrollar anticuerpos contra el sars
co2 para luego reproducirlos en
laboratorio los anticuerpos que hayan
sido capaz de neutralizar la infección
en células evaluaremos en hamsters y
también pueden disminuir las la
infección y los síntomas que produce
esta enfermedad en este modelo animal el
proyecto se encuentra en una primera
fase
separar esa
y aunque se requerirá probar su
eficiencia los investigadores peruanos
son optimistas en conseguir resultados
favorables él camélido sudamericano ha
sido estudiado en experimentos del vih y
la gripe y su eficacia contra otros
coronavirus como el sars o merz ha sido
aprobado otros modelos animales no
producen estos nano anticuerpos no
entonces esa es la razón por la cual es
diferentes investigadores grupos de
investigación usan camélidos como la
llama alpaca o incluso otros
que no tenemos aquí en el antiguo perú
la llama fue un animal con mucho valor
simbólico y de gran utilidad hoy la
ciencia revaloriza sus cualidades
y potito tito es una de varias llamas
bajo la lupa de científicos de
inglaterra bélgica y eeuu
quito la esperanza de los científicos
peruanos es todo en el por el momento
aquí en kobe 19 la semana en américa
puede dejar todos sus comentarios a
través de las redes sociales de france
24 nosotros
nos volvemos a encontrar la próxima
semana hasta entonces
[Música]